c'est une énorme déception
d'autant plus que cela fait cinq ans que
toutes les équipes travaillent
d'arrache-pied pour la bonne mise en
oeuvre et le bon déroulement de ce
contrat c'est vraiment en bon français à
coup dans le dos nous avions établi avec
l'australie une relation de confiance
cette confiance est trahie
[Musique]
taking my
story
[Musique]
on voit bien qu'il s'agit d'une
manoeuvre pour associer britanniques et
les australiens dans la fameuse
coalition que les états unis veulent
mener contre la chine en exportant une
nouvelle technologie qui la technologie
nucléaire la technologie nucléaire n'est
absolument pas dominé par les
australiens donc ça va être de
l'exportation américaine
[Musique]
j'imagine que pour les premiers salariés
concernés ils ont dû prendre une espèce
de chape de plomb sur eux à au réveil
j'ose espérer que nos premiers
dirigeants ont un effet de surprise
modéré et qu'ils ont un plan b pour
donner une suite à l' aventure de ses
500 salariés
[Musique]